it's amazing that we have had this
opportunity to change and I hope that
other people can learn from it too Katy
Perry is opening up about her
reconciliation with Taylor Swift and the
events that led to her epic cameo in the
you need to calm down music video
[Music]
the singer stopped by kiss 105 six the
Kyle and Jackie O show and revealed what
happened months ago when she wanted to
make amends with Taylor I just thought
you know she was about to embark on
something new and big and needed the
support and and truly it was like as I
was finishing mine I realized how much
we have in common and maybe there's only
five other people in the world that can
have the same type of conversations and
understand where we're coming from and
that we should celebrate our commonality
and our friendship and to be able to be
there for each other
Katie said that after she saw Taylor
around it to the parties she decided to
approach her I just went up to her and I
was like hey you know I spent a long
time and I think we we've grown up a
little bit and I just wanted to say I'm
sorry and that I'm really here for you
and that I love you and you know I hope
that we can be friends in the future the
34 year old said the next step was quote
talking a little bit and trusting each
other and finally they agreed to talk it
out she invited me over to her house and
she made me some cookies and she
actually makes those cookies and they
are actually so delicious of course
those cookies she's talking about are
the cookies Katie posted on Instagram in
June with the words peace at last
written on the plate in red frosting I'm
so excited
and naturally fans of the pop stars
freaked out when Katie captioned the
shot quote feels good at Taylor Swift
teasing they had put that bad blood
behind them
[Music]
but Katie did make one surprising
request before going to Taylor's house I
said the only way I'm coming to your hat
the house is this I can hold your new
cat well we all know what happens next
the two made peace and teamed up for
this iconic moment in Taylors you need
to calm down video
[Music]
I can trust her and she can trust me and
and you know we'll see each other in in
the halls of the music industry and not
avoid each other and Neil will embrace
and I think it's amazing that we have
had this opportunity to change and I
hope that other people can learn
something too Taylor also opened up
about putting the feud behind her during
an interview with BBC Radio 1 in June
when we saw each other it was just very
clear everything was different that we
had grown up that we had grown past
allowing ourselves to sort of be pitted
against each other and it just was
really really clear that we remembered
how much we had in common and so both of
us have been in a really good place for
a while but we didn't I don't think
either of us really knew if we were ever
gonna talk about it publicly well
clearly they have and now fans want to
collab check out what Katie told et in
March about the possibility of a Katie
Taylor track we're so excited to get new
music from you but here's the thing
Taylor Swift was just on this carpet
before you what about the rumors that
Katy Perry and Taylor Swift could make
music together
I mean I'm making music with Zedd I'm
open open open open
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]